will the new season go on with or
without them
i got the status of their idol return
from mr luke bryan
american idol season four virtual
auditions
are happening what next week i think it
is are we going to be seeing you
katie lionel right up there again at the
judge's table
yo i mean we're still in negotiations
but i can speak for
for myself that i certainly want to be
in the judges table and you know being
there with lionel and katie i mean
our chemistry is so natural so real so
fun that was amazing dude i'm a huge fan
katie's gonna be a new time mama which
is insane she let me know
the due date she's pretty close and
probably gonna send a little girl maybe
like a little pink
bb gun you know a country boy version of
a
katy perry's little baby girls baby gift
luke will soon have a new baby too
his seventh studio album born here live
here die here
is out friday in the song one margarita
is luke's 25th
number one country hit
[Music]
i'm really really blessed to be putting
an album out that's already had
kind of three number ones
[Music]
born here live here die here is about
growing up in a small town
tipping my hat and paying homage to
those people uh so now i'm just excited
for the fans to get it i hope they enjoy
it both luke's wife and mom were
featured in his one margarita music
video and now his mom
is quite a star on instagram as well
hello
this is luke's mama she was getting some
flowers on her front step from an
unknown sender i was like okay mama
i don't know who did it but thank you
somebody go on instagram and date my
mother please she needs her
man damn speaking of men blake shelton
have you uh
talked or heard from blake and gwen
during this whole pandemic phase
i actually have talked to blake and gwen
quite a bit like i laugh
every time because you got gwen stefani
you know california girl and now she's
out in the middle of a field with blake
shelton with like a
farming truck slash trucker hat on i'm
like
how could this girl ever have predicted
this would be her life